the six-time senator is trying for the
US presidency again picking up some
pizza from a restaurant just hours after
the news broke he was asked by reporters
if he had a special message for the
world yes America's coming back like we
used to be ethical straight tell him the
truth moving it away
supporting our ally good things but made
his announcement on Twitter saying the
soul of the nation was at stake taking
direct aim at Donald Trump's bid for
re-election Biden joins an already
crowded field of 19 other Democratic
hopefuls competing for their party's
nomination but there's a lot that could
work in his favor Biden has legislative
and international experience
that is unmatched by his rivals he
served as President Obama's vice
president for eight years and as a
senator since the 1970s but Biden is
already twice run for president
unsuccessfully in 1988 and 2008 and his
ages are worried to some at 76 he would
be the oldest person to ever take office
if elected so does his third run for the
White House come a little too late I
think that it's good he's running and I
support him so the party's dragging
itself away left he's not progressive
enough I would like to see someone else
that isn't that isn't old and white get
to that point personally like I'm all
about women and people of color and
equal opportunities and everything like
that but ultimately the person who could
best represent the people regardless of
their color their race their orientation
anything like that is my ultimate
concern Biden's ultimate concern right
now will be trying to connect with
voters
more effectively than any of his rivals
democratic or republican our
correspondent Oliver sallet sent us his
assessment from Washington Joe Biden
enters the race at a very interesting
moment in the run-up to the primary
elections the Democratic Party shifted
to the left there's a record number of
candidates running minorities are
represented women young candidates for
Joe Biden is none of that he's 76 years
old he's considered an old white man if
you will but yet he is the most popular
of all candidates and he has credibility
among blue-collar voters and that can be
crucial this time around in 2016 most of
the swing states went to Donald Trump
and Joe Biden wants to make the case
that he can be the one to win these
states back and defeat Donald Trump in
2020 but first of all he has to win the
primary elections and become the
official candidate of the Democratic
Party